hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain an American Psychological
neo-gothic horror film called a cure for
wellness spoilers ahead watch out and
take care
the protagonist of the movie Lockhart is
a self-centered young man who doesn't
care about anything other than his work
he is so career obsessed that he has
left his mother in an old age home
believing she is a distraction in the
opening scene he is called to a meeting
with the company's higher-ups and fellow
board members there he reads an open
letter from the CEO Pembroke who
addresses the board members he reveals
that he is currently at a Wellness Spa
in Switzerland on a two-week getaway
however in the letter Pembroke expresses
no intention to return and he calls out
the company for engaging in illegal and
unethical Financial practices Pembroke
also says that he would never approve
the company's planned merger with
another Finance Giant and warns the
board members against contacting him
ever again after going through the
troubling ladder the members unanimously
assign Lockhart to bring Pembroke back
to New York they warn him that if he
fails to do the job he'll have to take
the fall for the entire Scandal left
with no choice Lockhart agrees and
travels to svitzerland after touching
down he has driven a up the hill to the
spa by a man named Enrico the two strike
up a conversation and Enrico says that
he doesn't understand why rich people
from all over the world come looking for
this particular Spa their conversation
is interrupted when an angry villager
Chucks a drink at the car however Enrico
doesn't even respond implying that this
is a common thing here he explains that
the villagers have a bad history with
the people that live on the hill two
centuries ago the hill was owned by an
aristocratic family apparently the
Family's last Baron was so obsessed with
the purity of his bloodline he decided
that only his sister was clean enough to
carry his child when the Church
disapproved of the union he renounced
God please dear Lord jabus help me with
banging my sister what what do you mean
no this didn't go down well with the
Villagers and on The Baron's wedding
night they attacked and burnt the
illicit couple alive before leveling the
entire Castle after that the place was
rebuilt and turned into a wellness spa
for the rich people who come here
looking for the cure for their emptying
in the next scene Lockhart arrives at
the spa but learns that the visiting
hours have already ended therefore he
takes an appointment to speak with the
manager he then goes outside to make a
call and there he notices a window to an
eerie looking basement after a while he
finally meets the manager and asks to
speak with Pembroke after taking vitamin
droplets from A peculiar Blue Bottle the
manager tells him that their treatments
are most effective when exposure to the
stresses of the modern world are
strictly limited he reveals that the spa
is built over an ancient aquifer that
offers rejuvenating qualities Lockhart
looks at the pictures in the room and
notices a man with bandages all over his
body posing in front of the main
building however his gaze is abruptly
Disturbed when the manager tells him to
come back after seven in the evening
when Pembroke will be done with his
daily treatment before leaving Lockhart
drinks a glass full of water and thanks
the manager for cooperating
unfortunately on their way out of the
Hill a deer suddenly comes out of the
woods and Strikes the car it somehow
gets lodged in the windshield and due to
the ensuing struggle and Rico loses
control of the car and ends up crashing
into a ditch dear God three days later
Lockhart wakes up in a room at the same
Spa shortly after the director of the
place volmer approaches him and explains
that he broke his leg in the accident
Vollmer says that he has already
notified Lockhart's firm about the
accident and asks him to try out the
Spa's treatments during his stay after
he leaves Lockhart drinks water as he
watches a man covering the window to the
basement he saw earlier to his horror he
then finds a parasitic creature floating
in his glass following this Lockhart
sneaks out of the room and finds
Pembroke in the bath house he asks the
old CEO to come home with him but the
latter claims that he can't leave
because he is unwell Pembroke then takes
a dip in the water and when he emerges
he suddenly redevelops interest in the
stock market as if he is broken out of a
spell hence he agrees to return to New
York and Lead his company once again
excited Lockhart quickly gets ready and
calls for a taxi as he waits for
Pembroke he meets amateur historian
Victoria Watkins she shows Lockhart the
remains of the church where the baron
apparently executed a priest It is
believed that people used to come from
miles for the Miracles attributed to the
holy water Lockhart then tells her about
The Baron's obsession with bloodline
Purity and she promises to look more
into it after a while he meets the
youngest patient at the institution
Hannah she considers herself a special
case because she is the only patient who
is allowed to take the vitamins from a
blue bottle that vulner and the other
staff take later when Pembroke doesn't
show up and goes missing from his room
Lockhart confronts volmer the latter
claims that pembroke's condition
suddenly deteriorated and he had to be
moved to the next stage of the treatment
Lockheed accuses him of lying and calls
him out for deliberately making his
patients sick to keep milking them for
money like cows like little cows just
then Lockhart's nose starts to bleed and
he collapses Dr Vollmer takes him to his
clinic for a few tests and there
Lockhart notices Hannah's picture on his
desk when asked about it Vollmer claims
that she's special to him because she
experienced a serious trauma when she
was very young shortly after he reads
Lockhart's medical report and recommends
that he undergo treatment The Arrogant
American hesitantly agrees and when
vulner is distracted he steals
pembroke's medical file Lockhart then
undergoes treatment inside a water tank
however during it the manager gets
distracted and the tank suddenly fills
up with eels causing Lockhart to panic
he tries to escape but in the process
his breathing tube is pulled off by an
eel he almost drowns until the manager
pulls him out of the water just in time
Lockhart breathes a sigh of relief and
complains about the eels but to his
astonishment they have disappeared from
the water God damn imaginary eels
Lockhart then returns to his room and
goes through pembroke's file right then
when he looks through the window he
notices a man taking a patient into the
former Church the next morning Lockhart
asks his historian friend Watkins about
the church but she doesn't know what it
is used for now instead she tells him
that he was right about the baron and
his sisters illicit Affair however the
villagers didn't burn the place down
because of that reason turns out that
the baron was performing sick and
gruesome medical experiments on his
peasants the farmers started finding
disfigured human bodies dumped in their
fields dried up like the mummies of
Egypt fearing that they might be next
the residents of the village got
together and killed the royal couple
brutally once Victoria finishes saying
the story Lockhart figures that the
baron was probably looking for a cure to
treat the sick baroness suddenly a male
nurse appears and whisks Watkins away
for her treatment following this
Lockhart wanders around the place until
he notices Hannah riding her bike this
gives him an idea he asks her to show
him around the town and in exchange he
will give her a ballerina toy Hannah who
appears to be a child mentally agrees
without hesitation after a long and fun
ride they stop at a local Tavern for
some food to lock her its Delight he
finds Enrico there it turns out the
driver also survived the crash and he
was given a new car by The Wellness Spa
the reason however for this kind of
gesture was never specified meanwhile
law car has gets to know Hannah over
some beers she reveals that her mother
died in a fire when she was young and
that her father will come for her when
she gets cured she also lets him borrow
some of her vitamins Lockhart then
leaves Hannah at the bar to visit Peter
the only doctor in town although Peter
is a vet he looks at pembroke's medical
file and reveals that his teeth are
falling out probably due to Chronic
dehydration this puzzles Lockhart as the
spa makes its patients drink ample
amounts of water he connects it to The
Baron's experiments and the dried bodies
that were found in the field It is
believed the baron was burned alive 200
years ago but Lockhart finds it strange
the people are flocking to the spa
looking for a cure something the baron
was looking for for his sick wife pieter
reveals that her sickness was actually
infertility he then excuses himself to
Aid a dying cow turns out the cow fell
sick after drinking sewage water from
the spa he cuts the poor animal's
stomach open and shockingly a stillborn
calf and some eels spill out that was
oh God Lockhart then returns to the bar
and calls his boss back in New York to
his astonishments he learns that volmer
had never informed his superiors about
the accident the boss then orders
Lockhart to return to New York with
Pembroke within the next 24 hours
enraged Lockhart confronts Hannah and
asks her why no one is allowed to leave
the spa he also inquires about
pembroke's whereabouts and the blue
bottle vitamin the shy girl obviously
won't answer any of it and in a fit of
rage Lockhart gets into a fight with a
patron unfortunately things soon turn
South and Lockhart is about to be killed
but vulner arrives in the neck of time
and saves him without making a fuss he
then returns to the spa with the two
patients later that night Lockhart again
sees the staff moving patients into the
church his tooth also starts to fall out
and he reports this at the reception
when the nurse goes to fetch him some
medicine he goes through a file and
locates pembroke's room on his way there
Lockhart comes across Watkins he tells
her that The Baron's experiments are
happening again and in return she
reveals that the baroness wasn't
infertile Kyle because she was pregnant
at the night of the wedding if she was
pregnant with calves and baby eels I'm
noping out before she was burned alive
the baby was cut out of her womb and
thrown into an aquifer but it survived
later Lockhart finds the room where
Pembroke is supposed to be staying to
his shock the old CEO and several other
patients have been put inside water
tanks Lockhart tries to free Pembroke
but without success suddenly vulner
arrives there and catches him in the act
as a punishment he straps Lockhart down
and drills a hole in his front tooth in
the next scene Lockhart somehow escapes
from the spa and heads to town with
Enrico he goes straight to the local
police station and reports all of
walmer's experiments soon the evil
director is called into the station and
Lockhart accuses him of continuing
Baron's experiments and killing Pembroke
however volmer instead accuses him of
buying into Watkins conspiracy theories
he then calls Pembroke inside revealing
that the CEO is Alive and Well puzzled
by the whole incident Lockhart assumes
that he was hallucinating earlier so he
voluntarily returns to the spa with Dr
Gaslight later he undergoes several
treatments because of which he slowly
begins to act and think like Pembroke he
starts believing that he is not well and
that he must stay for a cure however one
day as Lockhart is writing a note to his
employers he suddenly has a Moment of
clarity he breaks a glass and uses one
of its shards to cut open his cast to
his shock Lockhart learns that his leg
was never broken he then breaks open the
gate to the church and Ventures inside
there he finds volmer's laboratory where
he conducts his experiments Lockhart
also finds an underground area with a
pool where dead bodies are dumped and
fed to eels one of those dead bodies
happens to be Mrs Watkins apparently she
knew too much for her own good so they
fed her to the eels suddenly Lockhart is
discovered by a worker but he manages to
neutralize him before running away
meanwhile Hannah is using the pool and
she has her first period soon eel starts
swimming near her in a perfect circle
for some reason they don't harm her at
all however Hannah
and immediately gets out of the pool she
starts running through the rooms until
she runs into Lockhart the latter tries
to explain what's going on but a
frightened Hannah hits him and runs away
following this she approaches Vollmer
who is having dinner with his patients
Lockhart also follows her and shuts at
the top of his lungs that vulmer is a
liar and that he is deliberately making
everyone Sick by contaminating their
water unfortunately the patients don't
believe him and instead gang up on him
Lockhart passes out and later wakes up
locked in a chamber soon vulmer
approaches him and starts revealing
everything he mentions that the eels
only live for a few years but in the
Spas aquifer they live for as long as
300 years but for humans this same water
is considered toxic which explains why
most of the patients are falling sick
however centuries ago the baron found
out that a proper filtration process
could turn the water drinkable for even
humans this process was not a normal one
though as the filters were alive humans
who had to go through a great deal of
pain the baron obviously didn't care
about any of it so he sacrificed
hundreds of of unwilling peasants until
he was killed by the angry mob after
revealing all this vulmer forces a tube
down Lockhart's throat through which the
creepy eels enter his stomach they then
filter out the vitamins from his
digestive system which apparently makes
one Immortal following this Lockhart has
his teeth fixed and he appears to be
changed just like the rest of the
patients stuck in a delusion that he is
unwell meanwhile Vollmer gives Hannah a
new dress and marries her now that she
has experienced her first period he
wants to copulate with her and continue
their bloodline oh God damn back in his
room Lockhart again has a Moment of
clarity when he goes through watkins's
notes he finds a portrait that was taken
a while after the fire he breaks the
portrait and lo and behold he notices
the man with bandages holding hands with
a little girl she is none other than
Hannah it turns out that vulner is the
baron and Hannah is his daughter God
damn he somehow survived the fire and
lived for two centuries disguised as
different personalities all this while
he can continued his experiments in the
guise of running a Wellness Spa he
killed innocent people extracted the
vitamins from their digestive systems
and consumed them to remain Immortal he
also gave it to Hannah and this is the
reason why she considers herself special
in the next scene vulner brings her to a
room and tries to do bad things to her
fortunately Lockhart arrives there just
in time to stop him this infuriates
volmer and he finally reveals his
scarred face he then attacks Lockhart
but the latter ducks and sets the room
on fire in no time the fire spreads
toward the rest of the castle Lockhart
tries to free Hannah but vulner attacks
him and drags him to the edge of the eel
pool in an attempt to finish him off
however Hannah who at this point has
realized that her father is a monster
somehow frees herself and rushes to
rescue Lockhart just in time she strikes
vulmer with a shovel and shoves him into
the pool making him eel food Lockhart
and Hannah then Escape just as the
patients and staff flee the Burning
Castle they take Hannah's bike and ride
away into the dead of night on the road
the duo runs into Lockhart's bosses who
have arrived to check up on the
situation they ask Lockhart about
Pembroke but he tells them that the old
man is gone they then tell him to get in
the car but he refuses the movie ends as
Lockhart continues riding away into the
night with a Sinister grin on his face
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching